[Music]
if you ever used snapchat you probably
loved playing with the Face Swap filter
to have fun with your friends just as
much as we do
and now your favorite Disney Princesses
and characters are joining the party and
the results are hilarious just wait
until you see what Moana and Maui look
like if this is your first time visiting
our channel don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up sit back as we show you 20 funniest
Disney face swaps Rapunzel and Pascal we
are supposed to use the face swap filter
with another human but we all have to
admit that we wanted to try it with our
dog it didn't work properly but that's
just what makes it even more hilarious
and this Disney Princess knows that
imagination has no limit when it comes
to having fun rapunzel now has the face
of a chameleon and Pascal is a young
woman by the look of it it seems like
this green creature loves wearing a
beautiful dress and the young princess
is jealous of his look we would love to
see a chameleon falling in love it would
be a story about showing your true
colors Pocahontas and John many of us
know that the story of this Native
American is not as pretty as Disney
wants us to believe Pocahontas was only
a child when John Smith came to America
she was badly treated by these strangers
was taken to Europe and had to marry
another John but what if this story was
different here's what they look like
when we swapped their faces but we want
to know what it would be like if they
swapped their lives we would love to see
Native Americans traveling to Europe and
instead of taking their lands they would
simply teach them about the beauty of
nature now that's a true love story that
we would like to watch if you want to
watch just one more video the premium is
the platform where you should go get
early access to videos from the things
the taco the trendy the richest and many
other great channels in one place with
ad free browsing click this link to sign
up for free to the premium and get ready
to binge watch videos from your favorite
channels
Sebastian and Ariel we have already seen
what it looks like when we swap our face
with an animal but the result is funnier
when it is a sea creature mostly if it
is not a real one
we know that Sebastian has a lot of
funny facial expressions and now we want
to see them on someone else just take a
look at Ariel and Eric if they have the
same face as this sea creature this is
not the romantic scene that we are used
to seeing we think that this is even
better
if only Ariel were so expressive the
prince would be able to clearly
understand what she was unfortunately it
would not be possible to kiss the girl
because she has no lips
Kuzco and pocha we can never get enough
of faye swaps with animals so here's
another one for you
Shak is transformed into a seal these
pictures never stop being funny if you
love animals you would probably like to
watch The Emperor's New Groove as Cusco
is transformed into a wama by his ex
advisor yzma it looks like she didn't
only give him the wrong magic potion but
also messed up with the ingredients
because the Emperor is still part human
and he doesn't seem too happy about it
and neither does the village leader who
found him we hope that pocha will
quickly find a way to help him we think
that this llama looks a little
terrifying Belle and Gaston he might
think that he is the most handsome man
on earth who deserves to marry the most
beautiful woman but we think that Gaston
will change his mind when he sees what
his face looks like unbell when we see
how Pedro fit query for BuzzFeed
reimagined her we are not sure that we
would like to say bonjour when we see
her on the street we think that we would
be avoiding her if we saw her on the
street Gaston might look a little better
but this enormous chin keeps distracting
us from looking at his beautiful eyes at
least this would truly be a story about
inner beauty we will have to call this
movie the beasts and the beasts Jasmine
and Jafar it's easy to spot the good and
the bad characters in Disney movies
kind princess is beautiful and the mean
antagonist is ugly we all know that in
real life it can be completely the
opposite and it can cause a lot of
trouble so let's imagine what it would
be like if these two characters from
Aladdin swapped faces Jasmine would be
ugly and Jafar would be good-looking do
you think this new version of jasmine
would marry Jafar because she is less
confident because of her look absolutely
not everyone knows that an evil person
can never truly be beautiful but being
nice immediately makes you prettier like
a diamond in the rough
Aladdin will give her a chance and
quickly see her inner beauty Flynn and
Rapunzel the princess let her hair grow
during all her life to keep it's magic
power
and it seems like she let a little more
facial hair grow when we look at this
face swap just look at her with the face
of Flynn Ryder we thought that these
characters were really good-looking but
we maybe changed our minds when we saw
their faces on another body and we think
that this story would be hilarious if
they exchanged their personalities too
it's always funny to see someone who has
a beard trying to swap his face with
someone else just look at the picture of
this father and his baby together they
are hilarious
Esmeralda and Quasimodo The Hunchback of
Notre Dame is the story of a deformed
man who develops a friendship with a
gypsy woman
Esmeralda he quickly falls in love with
her but sees her in the arms of another
man before he can reveal his true
feelings but if you read the original
story you would know that Phoebus was
actually the bad guy being so beautiful
caused a lot of problems to Esmeralda
maybe if she swapped her face with
Quasimodo her story would be really
different they would love each other for
who they are and she would attract fewer
bad guys he tried to take advantage of
her only for her beauty who said that
nice guys always have to finish last
Ariel and Ursula when the Little Mermaid
met her prince charming she was ready to
do anything for him so an Ursula offered
to give her legs in exchange for her
voice she immediately accepted but what
if Ursula asked her to swap her face
instead
as pedro fake we re reimagined her this
story would have been really different
but also less interesting to look at
would Eric saved this weird-looking
creature lying on the beach this guy has
a heart of gold so we think you will and
as she would still be able to talk she
would be able to explain to him all this
crazy story and they'll live happily
ever after but this adventure would be
way too short to tell so we prefer the
original one Tiana and Naveen when you
see handsome people you wish that you
could have a good-looking face like them
but sometimes it only looks good on
their body just take a look at Brad Pitt
and Angelina Jolie we are happy to see
that the actress doesn't grow a beard in
real life it doesn't look as pretty as
her beautiful hair but now let's take a
look at our favorite Disney characters
swapping faces just as they were getting
ready for their wedding it seems like a
little incident happened Naveen seems
confused about the look of the bride but
he can't complain he was a frog when
Tiana first met him and we have to admit
that we would love to see a face swap of
a human with a frog aladdin and Jasmine
this is probably one of our favorite
Disney movies the street rat is a true
diamond in the rough growing up as a
thief but always doing what's good it's
no surprise that Jasmine thought that
this man was really charming when she
got the chance to know him but did you
know that a Ladin didn't always look the
way he does he wasn't really handsome at
first but the animators thought that the
princess was too beautiful to fall in
love with a guy like this this is why he
was modeled after Tom Cruise instead now
do you want to see what they look like
with a different face here they are and
it is pretty funny Anna and Kristoff who
said that every princess needed a prince
Anna found out that a normal guy could
be much more charming and Elsa always
knew that she was better off alone than
in bad company but let's go back to the
cutest couple of the movie it wasn't
love at first sight and it is better
this way when we see what happened with
Hans Kristoff and Anna didn't like each
other at first but they quickly found
out that when you don't get what you
want
you could get what you need if only they
could swap faces they could see how
ridiculous they both look when they
argue with each other difference doesn't
have to be a bad thing they will later
realize that it's actually what they
like the most about each other
snow-white and grumpy the fairest of
them all had to run away from her home
because her stepmother was jealous of
her beauty she found a place to hide and
was happy to hear that the dwarfs
welcomed her into their home but if the
princess looked like these short and
funny characters we think that this
story would have been really different
if the young girl had a big nose like
that the Evil Queen wouldn't have to
care about the competition she would
like to keep snow-white by her side to
feel prettier next to her but no matter
what she looks like on the outside Snow
White will always be the fairest of them
all on the inside and we are pretty sure
that her prince charming will see that
to Hercules and Philoctetes we have seen
a lot of people and characters swapping
their faces with animals but the fun
doesn't stop there
you can Face Swap with almost anything
including objects you probably don't
have a half human half goat friend at
home but let's see what the funny
Philoctetes looks like next to Hercules
we know that he has a big heart but the
satyr can easily be annoyed by other
people if Hercules had this personality
we think that he would be going from
hero to zero because of his behavior the
nose doesn't suit him either but as a
sidekick and trainer Philoctetes is
absolutely perfect and we think that he
would love to have Hercules face to
flirt with women Abu and the merchants
poor Abu didn't have anything to eat so
we can't be mad at him when he tries to
steal things if we had to choose between
starving or becoming a thief it would be
a matter of life and death to solve all
our problems we would just have to swap
their faces now the merchant looks
really happy to give away his food and
the monkey makes us laugh even more if
only everyone could be as generous as
Aladdin we would be living in a better
world the merchant has a lesson to learn
from that just like a poo
when he saw his role model give bread to
the children Pocahontas and Ratcliffe as
soon as we saw a governor Ratcliffe we
knew that he wasn't going to America to
do something good in Disney movies it is
pretty easy to recognize the bad
characters at first sight but do you
know what would be worse if the governor
had a beautiful face like Pocahontas
just like Pedro feck we re reimagined
him many people would trust him more
easily and he would have more power to
get rid of Native Americans if only it
was like that in real life we would love
people to get uglier every time they are
mean to recognize who is evil but maybe
needing to get to know people is a
necessity that we should learn to
appreciate everyone deserves the chance
after all Tarzan and Jane
we haven't watched this movie in a long
time and this is why we should organize
a Disney Marathon let's watch all our
favorite movies in one night and Tarzan
has to be part of our list in the movie
a young boy is raised by a gorilla in
the forest in Africa
growing up he thought that there was no
one else like him so he was surprised to
see explorers visiting the forest when
he saved Jane but what if this young
woman looked even more like him what if
she had the same face after all birds of
a feather flock together and most of us
are attracted to those who are similar
to us they are probably one of the most
surprising couples we have ever seen
Jafar and the genie genie is probably
one of our favourite Disney characters
ever we love is funny facial expressions
and how he changes his shape to become a
new character if we can have our wish it
would be to always have him by our side
this is why we couldn't wait to see a
face swap of him with another character
and the lucky one turned out to be Jeff
R he looks really surprised what do you
think he saw we hope that it is Jasmine
in the arms of Aladdin because we love
to see these two together but no matter
what watching their reaction is probably
funnier than what is in front of them
Ariel and Eric we are tired of seeing
princes saving the damsel
this dress this time we don't only want
these characters to swap their faces we
also want them to swap their lives Erik
will be the Merman living under the sea
and Ariel will be the princess living on
the land but we bet that if this man
gives away his voice in exchange for
legs that won't be too much of a problem
we heard that women are sometimes better
at understanding body language so maybe
the princess will be able to guess what
he wants but would she have the courage
to make the first step and kiss the boy
this is a story that we would love to
see in a Disney movie Moana and Maui and
last but not least is Moana and Maui
they might look different as the
semi-god is huge and the young woman
looks really tiny next to him but don't
judge them only by their looks
Moana is actually the one who has the
strongest personality and Maui has a
heart as big as his belly together they
make the perfect team to go on a crazy
adventure so what would they look like
with their faces swapped here they are
and the result is really hilarious are
there any other duo's that you would
like to see don't be shy to tell us who
it is in the comment section down below
and that's it for 20 funniest Disney
face swaps for more stories like this
make sure you watch ten Disney
Princesses reimagined as parents thanks
for watching
[Music]